ghostwriter he's back in three two one
[Music]
whoa
i thought moving here and starting a new
school would be hard
but
i found friends i never imagined i'd
find siobhan curtis and donna
it changed everything
there's a logical explanation it's a
ghost i think the ghosts can only
communicate with written words the ghost
writer
do you have the time there's a talking
rabbit that nobody can see but us i
think the rabbit from this book has
escaped we'll let him out the ghost
who's been sending us messages
what is this what are you doing
horrifying
what if your grandma's ghost writer
grandpa said even though grandma's gone
she'll always be with us like a ghost
and they only hang around when they have
unfinished business let's do this your
grandma had this old letter secret
letter it must have been important we
need to find that letter
school's right to let the characters out
of the book
grandma wouldn't have sent them here
unless they were important to the
mystery promos letter
who's s the mystery is nowhere close to
being solved
i'm pretty good at solving mysteries
sparkles they're memories left behind by
other people
oh that's my grandma there was a weird
guy that gave a check to grandma and it
was inside the mason bricks book
[Music]
that's grandma's letter so that person
is us but who is it
we need to find him
that lady that used to work here my
grandma she was sure that this bookstore
was haunted
if my grandma's not ghost writer then
who have we been talking to all this
time
gold sweater wasn't releasing your
paintings
the character in this case would be the
paintbrush
cobalt mask the painting
there's no author that's a first
break is from a poem he's a spy he's
also from a bunch of mason breaks books
mason briggs wrote detective fiction at
which point he drops off the map now the
cobalt mask never came out and he is an
unpublished manuscript mason briggs has
to be involved in the mystery somehow
sherlock holmes dr watson we need help
solving the case let the facts lead you
mason briggs is a pseudonym
this photo allowed us to find the real
mason bricks
this technology is fantastic i'm kidding
sherlock
if we find this view we find the
manuscript
look
nice view
check this out
we're so close to finishing the mystery
time travel this is incredible
pirates dinosaurs
did that rat just drop that car
this is gonna be interesting
ghost raiders has been preparing us for
this moment
we're running out of time
we went into the book we became book
characters styling
oh this food is so amazing didn't you
eat breakfast this morning yeah but book
eggs taste way better